besides Christine Ford and Cavanaugh
himself the chief figure of today's
hearing was the Arizona prosecutor
Rachel Mitchell did she ask the right
questions or miss anything important
possibly a rhetorical question Francie
Hicks is a former DOJ National
Coordinator for Child Exploitation
prevention and interdiction and she
joins us tonight
as I watched these hearings today I kept
thinking how alone Brett Kavanaugh was
I'm not attacking the prosecutor who
asked the questions on behalf of
Republican senators in the first half
but Cavanaugh seemed to be the only one
making a case for Cavanaugh you know
Tucker unfortunately I agree with you
although the way I look at it is that
Cavanaugh was the only person even
trying to challenge the allegations
which I think was the role of Miss
Mitchell and well I think she did a
couple of things well establishing
possible political bias and the sense of
the delay of the hearing you know this
ridiculous allegation that she was
afraid to fly she certainly blew that
one out of the water and this out of
this this elucidation of the issue of
whether or not ms Ford or dr. Ford
delayed in her own words coming forward
with his information she said that she
knew about Brett Cavanaugh's position on
the short list and that she was
determined to prevent his nomination and
yet somehow this PhD was unable to
figure out how to call either of her two
senators both of whom sit on the
Judiciary Committee so I thought miss
Mitchell did a good job with that but
when it came to asking about the
allegations I was shocked when she told
dr. Ford that she would not be asking
her about those allegations at all and
she didn't right it's like buying a new
car but not mentioning price I I have to
say on the plane thing though I wondered
about I mean she established that
Christine Ford has flown an awful lot
but I thought what she could have teased
out a little bit is why she lied about
it in this case we can't come to
Washington to testify because she can't
get on an airplane this had a
politically significant effect delaying
the confirmation of Kavanagh that's a
lie
why is nobody saying that well I don't
know and I thought judge Kavanagh did
a brilliant job of explaining what that
delay has meant to him his family and
his reputation and their future
you know prosecutors like to say don't
ask a question you don't know the answer
to so don't ask a wide question all
trained prosecutors know that that's
just garbage you have to ask questions
you don't know the answer to that's what
happens in every trial you often don't
know the answer
she should have challenged dr. Ford and
she did not right yeah I noticed I was
grinding my teeth throughout France eyx
thank you very much thanks Tucker